the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care whose a busted that
starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
Season eight and Game Theory's video
today I will be talking about several
different topics I was actually watching
this show last night and I noticed a few
cool details that I did not pay much
attention to the last time I was
watching these episodes as I was sitting
there watching the show I was also
taking notes because I noticed a few
scenes that I think could be
foreshadowing some things to come in the
final season and I thought they were
worth mentioning I wasn't exactly sure
what I was going to title this video
because none of these scenes really
relate to each other but I did not want
to make separate videos for each
different topic so I will just go over
the scenes and tell you what I think it
could mean the first two scenes I want
to show you are connected to each other
and they both have to do with Winterfell
the actual castle itself the reason why
I think these scenes are so important is
because of what will most likely happen
during the final season as we all know
the night king is now south of the wall
and he's bringing about a hundred
thousand White's with him plus he has a
dragon and Giants obviously Westeros has
a major problem on its hands because the
night King appears to be ready for war
John and Daenerys are currently heading
to Winterfell to prepare for this threat
Daenerys has her two remaining dragons
and she has the Dothraki and the
unsullied John's army is already
stationed in the north so once they get
the Winterfell they will need to act
fast because the night King is already
on his way thanks to some spoiler photos
and videos we know there is going to be
a major battle at Winterfell which I
believe will involve the night Cain I
know some people think the night king
will bypass Winterfell and head south
instead but I disagree I think the night
king plans on a take on Winterfell for a
few different reasons the main reason is
because the night Kings biggest
opponents will be there we know that I
king wants to get the brand stark for
some reason it's not entirely clear if
he wants to kill bran or you
sym for something else but he is
definitely trying to reach bran Stark he
interacted with brain inside of the
weirwood net which allowed him to enter
the three-eyed Ravens cave bran and Mira
was able to escape but the night king
still sent White's after him but
thankfully Uncle Benjen was there to
give them an uber ride Jon Snow and the
knight King have a history together as
well so we know there needs to be a
payoff there and now Daenerys wants to
kill him too because he killed one of
her dragons bran John and Daenerys will
all be at Winterfell together so I would
be willing to bet money that they will
face off right there at the very first
castle we were introduced to in season 1
episode 1 I am actually of the belief
that Winterfell was actually the night
Kings home but I won't go into that
again in this video but we have already
seen plenty of evidence to know that
what there felt will come under attack
the castle was seen on fire and there
were dead bodies littered all over the
battlements most of you that watch all
my videos should already know this but
this only created even more questions
was it the night king who set the castle
on fire with Vasari on did the
Winterfell castle fall and forced the
Starks to flee south or did the night
king and his army get defeated at
Winterfell
these are all great questions that need
answered and we won't know for sure
until we see the episodes but my guess
has always been that Winterfell will not
fall the castle may burn but it will not
be destroyed entirely in fact I think
Jon and Daenerys will be victorious at
Winterfell I've talked about this before
but I want to show you these other
scenes that I haven't included in those
other videos about the Great War
beginning at Winterfell I believe this
is some pretty good foreshadowing and I
have Theon Greyjoy's to thank for these
little tidbits about Winterfell
Theon says these things after he seizes
Winterfell let's take a look at the
first clip this is shortly after a bran
and Rickon escape those boys were far
more value to your life than death they
have no value to me missing Robb will
have sent a force to retake Winterfell
by now
Robb's in the Riverlands my sister's in
Deepwood Motte she'll get here long
before they do a Ned Stark always said
500 men could hold Winterfell against
10,000 according to Theon he says Ned
Stark always said as long as you have
five
and Men you can defend Winterfell
against an attack from 10,000 men this
is a very important piece of information
because John and Daenerys will most
likely be outnumbered by the night Kings
forces but they don't need anywhere near
equal numbers to hold Winterfell against
his attack now I'm no mathematician but
if the knight King has a hundred
thousand whites that means John and
Daenerys would only need five thousand
men to defend to Winterfell
and we all know they have a hell of a
lot more than that I'm not sure how big
the northern army is after the battle
with the bastards but Daenerys has more
Dothraki and unsullied than that alone
now that the knight King has a dragon
that certainly changes these odds but
Daenerys still has two dragons and
drogon is the biggest of them all if
what Ned Stark said was true then the
stark should have no problem with
holding off an attack
I'm sure the producers of the show will
make sure the battle is dramatic that
way we think the good guys are about to
lose which is probably why the castle
burns but I don't think that means it's
a guaranteed loss for House Stark now in
case you're still on the fence about
this let me show you what else Theon
said about Winterfell I thought this was
even more interesting than the first
clip because this may be a big indicator
of how things end in the north first
time I saw Winterfell look like
something that had been here for
thousands of years and would be here for
thousands of years after I was dead I
saw it and I thought of course Ned Stark
crushed our rebellion and killed my
brothers we never stood a chance against
a man who lives here
Theon said the first time I saw
Winterfell it looked like something that
had been here for thousands of years and
would be here for thousands of years
after I'm dead I believe that means no
matter how badly Winterfell may be
damaged the castle will always remain it
will continue to stand for thousands of
years the castle has too much history
and magical elements to ever disappear
during this current story we have always
heard that a stark must remain in
Winterfell and I think this ties in to
the magic that was used when the castle
was originally built by Brandon the
Builder when the night King shows up
there will be a stark here in fact all
of the remaining Starks will be there
and when you consider how powerful brain
is right now I would bet Winterfell will
be very hard to take from the Starks now
that this ancient castle is back under
their control george RR martin plans on
releasing seven books to complete his A
Song of Ice and Fire series and he
intended on titling the last book a time
for wolves I don't know about you but to
me that sounds like the Starks are gonna
make a major comeback in the end then
again I know nothing let's move on to a
different topic this time I want to show
you a scene with Robin Talisa I think
they may have actually foreshadowed
something that could happen with John
and Daenerys I'm sure most of you know
this by now but I fully believe Daenerys
is pregnant and most of us have been
wondering what she will have well
Daenerys have a son or a daughter or
could she have both I have been thinking
about this a lot lately because
depending on what Daenerys has this
could determine the future of House
Stark and House Targaryen both of these
major houses are coming close to
extinction and if someone doesn't start
producing errors that's exactly what
will happen although I do believe John
and Daenerys will produce an error but
will they give it the stark name or
Targaryen name which house would they
save I think we all know what Daenerys
would do but what would John want to do
well they may be able to do both if this
scene is foreshadowing what will happen
so let's take a look
[Music]
I have your little prince or princess
inside me maybe one of each Talisa said
I have your little prince or princess
inside me and Rob said maybe one of each
Rob thought she could possibly have
twins even though we later find out
she's going to have a son but I think
this could foreshadow what will happen
with John and Daenerys maybe they will
be the ones to have twins then they
could give one kid the Targaryen name
and the other kid the stark name they
could kill two birds with one bone now I
know some of you may be thinking why
would is seen with Robin Talisa
foreshadow something about John and
Daenerys well if you remember Robin
tulisa's wedding it was actually
foreshadowing Rhaegar and Lyanna Spri
vut wedding binding them as one for
eternity
[Music]
look upon one another as their the words
father Smith warrior mother father Smith
warrior mother maiden Crone stranger
I'm hers she is mine
since their wedding foreshadowed Rhaegar
and Lyanna 'he's perhaps their
conversation about having twins is a
clue to what Daenerys will have it's
obviously not a guarantee but when I
heard Rob say they could have twins it
immediately made me think of John and
Daenerys because this could really help
solve the problem of House Stark and
Targaryen needing someone to carry on
the names anyways let's move on to this
other topic now the next thing I want to
show you is a scene between Qyburn and
Jaime Lannister this is shortly after
Qyburn helps fix Jaime's arm as they are
traveling to King's Landing they make a
stop and Qyburn looks after Jaime again
but they have a very interesting
conversation about Chi burns healing
methods I think this could be a clue as
to what Qyburn may plan to do now that
he has seen the whites for himself I did
make a video about this before but I did
not include this scene so let's take a
look at it then I will tell you what I
think it might mean for the endgame so
why did the Citadel take your chain
do you fondle one boy too many no my
lord that's not my weakness what is
curiosity the only way to treat disease
is to understand disease the only way to
understand it is to study the afflicted
so as you can see Jamie asked Qyburn why
the Citadel took his chain and Qyburn
said because of his curiosity
Qyburn was known for performing
experiments on people that were still
alive and this is a big no-no in the
eyes of the Citadel but Qyburn does make
a good point about why it is so
effective he said the only way to treat
disease is to understand disease the
only way to understand it is to study
the afflicted now the reason why I found
that quote so interesting was because it
immediately reminded me of what Qyburn
did during the dragonpit seen when the
Hound releases the white we can see Chi
burns curiosity at work it was Qyburn
securio city they got him stripped of
his chain while studying at the Citadel
but his curiosity could also give us
some more insight into how the army of
the Dead operates or functions since I
already made a video about this I won't
go into all of the same things again so
let me just propose this one as a
question to all of you
based on what Qyburn said to Jamie do
any of you think Qyburn took any of the
whites body parts to study
Qyburn may look at this the same way he
looks at a disease that is spreading the
only way to treat disease is to
understand it and to do that he would
need to study the afflicted the way he
inspected the whites hand made me think
he wanted to learn more about it now
John did burn the hand but the rest of
the whites body could still be looked at
this would certainly not be the first
time Qyburn was involved in some
unnatural practices booster
grand maester that is exactly the sort
of arrogance that had him expelled from
the Citadel your grace his curiosity was
deemed it might not actually be that
different from what is going on with the
mountain let me know what you think
about some of the scenes I showed you
today do you think any of them are
hinting at what will happen in the
future also tell me if you would like to
see more foreshadowing videos like this
one either way I want to thank all of
you for watching today's video I really
appreciate that and
I also want to give a big shout out to
everyone that supports the channel on
patreon have a great day I will see you
in the next video bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you